I'm going to tell you
two things in this talk.
First, how you can
build accessible
lessons with The Carpentries Workbench.
And second, how we used R to
build The Carpentries workbench,
which allowed us to
transform our lessons
from looking like this
to looking something
a bit more like this.
And I have a lot of people that
I need to thank for this talk,
including the RStudio
diversity scholars
program, which brought myself
and Dr. SherAaron, soon to be Dr. SherAaron
Hurt to this conference.
But I don't really have
the time to go over this.
And what you need to
know about this talk
is that you need to know who
The Carpentries are in order
to appreciate it and
in order to understand
who The Carpentries are.
I'm going to tell
you a little bit,
a little story about myself.
This is not a recent photo.
This was from 2014.
I was teaching my very
first conference workshop
in population genetics
and are giving it
to plant pathologists.
If you're wondering
what population
genetics in R is,
think 23andMe but for fungi.
So in this workshop I wrote
the, I wrote the materials
all in R Markdown.
I forced my, I forced
my advisor to use Git
and ended up fixing a
lot of merge conflicts.
And the process of building
this was very painful.
It was very much close your
eyes and hope it works.
I did end up building the
website, but that version of me
knew quite a lot about
population genetics,
knew quite a lot
about plant pathology,
didn't know very much about
inclusive teaching, lesson
design, or live coding.
And this workshop, it
was actually successful.
We ran it for two years,
got really good reviews.
People liked it, but something
was really bothering me.
Something was eating
me on the inside.
I didn't actually know
what people learned.
I knew they learned
something.
They had their computers open.
They were following along.
But I don't know
what they learned.
And here's the thing.
My advisor had no
way of supporting me
in that he was a
government scientist.
You know, like he hadn't
taught a course in years.
And so if I had a way to
get the support I needed,
such as maybe a template that
could have that could have
given me the narrative
elements and, and elements
for formative
assessment, I would
have been able to
succeed in understanding
what my learners
learned and then improve
that lesson over time.
And I know now that The Carpentries
provides that support
and gives a safe space
for improving my teaching.
And The Carpentries is all about
spreading data science skills
to research researchers around
the globe to really democratize
access to data.
And it does this by fostering
communities of practice.
And these are volunteers
who are trained
in evidence based
teaching principles
from all around the world.
And we all come together through
shared core values in that we
are motivated, in that
we are always learning
and we're inclusive of all.
In practice, we act openly,
we empower one another,
and we value all
contributions, which
allows us to achieve our
goals of championing people
first, access for all, community
collaboration, and strength
through diversity.
And we know that
it works because we
have led over 3,500 workshops
in the past 10 years
to over 60 countries.
3900 instructors, 45 lessons
to over 80,000 novice learners
and over 90 member institutions.
I know that's a lot of numbers.
But the key to this.
The reason why this works is
because our instructors never
teach alone in a
Carpentries workshop.
If you are an instructor,
if you're a new instructor,
you're always
paired with someone
who's taught this before.
And this is always possible
because of the efforts
of our director of
workshops, SherAaron Hurt,
who allows you, who
gives you the opportunity
to teach these workshops.
And these workshops
would not be possible
without our open source and
open license materials that
are available on GitHub.
And it's these
materials that I'm
going to talk about for
the rest of the talk,
because these have
a long history.
They were originally written
in HTML, just straight HTML,
really difficult to write
if you're really tired or.
Yeah eventually
they switched over
to jekyll, which is GitHub's
default site generator.
And I'm going to ask for a
little audience participation
here, so I'm going to
ask you three questions.
If the answer is yes, I want
you to clap twice with me.
So first question just
to get a baseline.
If you have ever used Jekyll.
Clap twice.
OK, good.
If you have ever uttered a
curse word while using Jekyll.
Clap twice.
That was about the same.
OK if you have ever wanted
to set your laptop on fire
while using Jekyll,
please clap twice.
OK so, yeah, Jekyll's
kind of hard to use.
And the thing is,
it's been shown
as a barrier when you're just
trying to build the lesson.
When you're trying
to work on a lesson,
you just want to fix a typo.
You want to update an image.
And if you find this.
You really want to
burn it all down?
It's not easy to use.
And the thing is, it wasn't
living up to our values.
This really did not
put people first.
This was putting
the machines first.
And so I was hired in 2020 to
reimagine this infrastructure
because it was clear it was
not living up to our values.
And what I realized
is that we really
need to separate the
tools from the content.
Anything everybody should
worry about is just
writing, being able to
write Markdown or R Markdown
and get a website
out of it and not
having to sift through
all the output that's
contained in the
same folder or having
to worry about tools breaking.
And so this is how I created
The Carpentries Workbench.
And this is a series
of packages that
avoids having a lesson
being wrapped around a blog
infrastructure.
And it keeps the tools
and output separate.
And it's based on the
philosophy of package
down, work where you are.
And this, it consists
of three packages.
The first package that
you're going to interact with
is sandpaper.
This is what
orchestrates everything.
The only command you really
need to know is sandpaper serve.
The next package
is on the inside.
And you don't interact with it.
So often, but you do with it.
You do sandpaper, uses
it in the back end
to help you validate
your markdown,
to make sure that
it actually is going
to do what you want it to do.
And then coming in
at the end is varnish
that allows you, that gives you
the styling of your lessons
to make sure that your lessons
are accessible and beautiful.
And all of this
was designed what
I like to call with, what I
like to call core values driven
design.
And so I'm going to talk
about a few of our core values
and how the design
elements fit in with them.
There are a lot more, but I
don't have that much time.
So the first thing
I'm going to I'm
going to start with is
championing people first,
because really, individuals
who make up our community
are the most important
part of our organization
and they are our
strongest resource.
So it only makes sense that when
I was looking for a static site
generator, something to generate
our websites, with that I
would choose something that had
the most on ramps and really.
R is the best resource.
It makes the most sense.
You saw it in Iliana's talk and
you see it here and this tweet
from Yanina Bellini,
and she says
that some people
laugh when I tell them
that R's best feature as
a language is its community.
But I'm very serious,
especially RLadies
has been such a positive agent
of change for so many people.
And that's one of the
reasons why y'all are here.
Like, we are a good
community here.
We know how to make
people feel included.
And so it only makes sense.
Another way that we're
championing people
first is that we virtually
increased the number
of instructors in the room.
When you're teaching a lesson
and I'm going to explain what
I mean by that.
So you have your lesson.
It has code examples,
and you want
to teach someone how to add
a column to a dataframe.
So you are working in RStudio
and you show them the code,
you run the code,
and then you have
output that looks like this.
You can't really tell what
happened because there are so
many columns in the dataframe.
Everything ran off the edge.
If you were.
If if you had the wisdom of the
instructors who came before you
and yes, you are teaching
with another instructor,
they may know this,
but they may not.
You would know that you have
to add a select command.
And so what we do is we allow
instructors to communicate
through time and
space by including
by allowing them to include
instructor notes directly
into the lessons in the
context that is needed.
So that when you
teach this lesson,
you can change your behavior
and you can show the learners
what exactly they need
to know and reduce
their cognitive load.
And another way we
champion people first
is that we include automation.
Oftentimes as you're building,
R Markdown, packages will update.
Things fail.
You get a lot of errors.
You get warnings
that don't make sense
because the package
authors change
their change their packages.
We avoid this by embedding renv.
renv sorry.
In on the back end of sandpaper.
And the beauty about this.
You don't need to know anything
about renv in order to use this.
We lock the packages, we give
you a way to update them,
and we give you a way to pin
them so that your lessons are
always working
and you have a way
to investigate what happens
when packages update.
And I'm going to show you
that some of that a little bit
later.
And really, this
leads me into the fact
that we championed
access for all.
Because it shouldn't
matter what packages
you have on your system.
It shouldn't matter
what packages you
have in your global library.
You should be able to
build the lesson the same.
Anyone else can
build the lesson.
And so.
I'm going to show
you, like what happens
when you don't have your own
computer, when you're not
on your own computer and
you receive a pull request
that changes a plot.
But can anybody
tell me what's going
to happen when this happens?
Probably not because
it's R code,
but seeing the output of
the plot is night and day.
And we and we have embedded
pull request previews
for the intermediate
Markdown, for these lessons.
So that you can confirm
that things actually
work whether or not you
have the tools installed.
And this is.
And furthermore, if you're
writing an R lesson,
sometimes you may forget to
add, to include, alternative text
or we have link descriptions
that don't actually describe
anything and you say, whoops.
And it's.
It's this kind of.
This kind of.
Pre-flight validation
that's done
by pegboard that allows you
to take a step back and say,
yeah, I made a
mistake and fix it.
And that's really
the key to, that's
really the key, to how we're
championing access for all.
And we're always learning
because we're humans.
You forget things.
You shouldn't be punished.
You shouldn't have,
like, glaring errors
when you miss something.
When you mistype something.
And it shows that
we're always learning
and I'm going to turn on myself.
I'm obviously.
Sandpaper is not the
fastest thing in the world.
The Workbench is not the
But I really want to address the
pink pachyderm in the premises.
We don't use Quarto yet.
Sorry, but the way I design,
the way I design the system,
we're going to include
Quarto in the future.
We just need to get it
stable in our system.
And I built it to
be flexible so it
works on the exact same
principle that Quarto works.
And then finally, I
want to get to the fact
that we empower one another.
The Workbench is
going to support
168 lessons come January.
And this is really key
because most of these lessons
are in The Carpentries incubator
in which people are actively
developing lessons, working
on lessons, testing them
out, teaching them
and getting feedback
and revamping them in
this iterative development
cycle that eventually leads to
peer review of lessons and the.
This is.
And The Carpentries Workbench
makes this model sustainable.
It makes it much
easier for people
to do these iterations with
all of these safeguards
that we've built into it.
And so.
It's here that I
want to show you
that it's, I'm not the
only one who thinks this.
I'm not the only
one who claims this.
Saba Ferdous.
This from UCL.
She's part of the
learn discover project.
She forked sandpaper
and made it run Python.
She and she says
that it was very
trivial and efficient
to write custom lessons.
With The Carpentries workbench,
I have a link there.
My slides are online.
I'll give you a
QR code for that.
Toby Hodges.
He's the curriculum lead of
The Carpentries.
He works with the
community, and he
says the carpentry
Workbench has made
it easier for people to write,
maintain and teach lessons
in many different ways,
sometimes quite profoundly.
Sarah Stevens very embedded
in The Carpentries, and she says,
I'm really excited to be
able to use the Workbench's
accessibility
features because she's
tired of not having
reminders to add alt text.
And finally, Francois Michonneau now
has been working with the car,
with the Workbench
since the beginning.
And he says you only have
to focus on writing content
and the Workbench
takes care of the rest.
And so here's a link
that you can use
and you can create your own
lesson using the Workbench.
And now you can build your own
accessible lesson using R.
But that's not what the
doc title is, y'all.
OK what about friends, huh?
This is building accessible
lessons with R and friends.
And this is where I put in
a plug for The Carpentries.
I want you all to get
involved because really we
are a great community.
There are plenty of
ways to become to be
involved in The Carpentries.
And it's really a
community of practice.
You get you get so many
opportunities to interact
with people who really
care about teaching.
You can become an instructor.
Next summer, we're going
to open up applications
for maintenance of our lessons.
You can teach,
create, contribute to
or review a lesson, or even
just take our materials
and they're there
completely open.
Or if you're part
of an organization,
you can have that
organization enroll
as a member and use that
to build your own community
in your organization.
And that's.
And if you want to
know more, we have
a conference that's happening
right after this conference.
It's online and we have
an accessibility fund,
if you want if you want to
donate to it, to make sure
that we have money for
translators, money for people
who do captioning and
it's free to attend.
So if you want to learn
more, please attend.
I have my slides.
I have information
about the Workbench.
I'd be happy to take any
questions if I have time.
OK Thank you.